so Edward Snowden was interviewed by
Brian Williams for the NBC Nightly News
and he laid a couple bombs I mean huge
breaking news we've got two clips for
you let's take a look first
I was trained as a spy and sort of the
traditional sense of the word and that I
lived and worked undercover overseas
pretending to work in a job that I'm not
and even being assigned a name that was
not mine but I am a technical specialist
I am a technical expert I don't work
with people I don't recruit agents what
I do is I put systems to work for the
United States and I've done that at all
levels from from the bottom on the
ground all the way to the top okay that
seems pretty huge nobody knew about this
even President Obama was saying he was a
low-level systems analyst or a low-level
hacker everyone in the government has
been saying that we obviously can hear
more about this but this is huge right I
don't know I don't know that it's huge
it's interesting and the debate about
who Eric's of Eric Snowden that's is
that the fake name was they an Edward
Edward Jesus right but I find the debate
about Edward Snowden interesting like
and and I like talking about it but it's
not really important like it still only
matters what he really still only
matters what he released and and you
know and and what we're gonna do about
it like it and the debate that comes
afterwards like of course the
administration tries to minimize him so
it doesn't really it doesn't really
surprise me you know and and does it
again
suppose it we find out that that he
should have that their argument could
quickly quickly shift from he's not high
enough ranking to know better to now
they could go he should have known
better
yeah you know so I mean I don't I that
that's why I don't it's interesting it's
it's credibly interesting I don't know
that really changes what the most
important discussions about this ought
to be yeah when you said that he dropped
two big bombs I thought it's because
he's eating a lot of Salvadorian food
but that wasn't the case and I like what
Brian Williams given us a serious face
which is nice
but then he had to take he didn't do a
follow-up cuz they did take off he had
an improv class over at the UCB he had
to get to right away yeah what are we
talking about Snowden yes a spy are you
surprised
yes because we've been again what what
what we've been told is that this guy is
a low-level he was then and I always
said well if he's so low-level how come
he has access to all this unbelievable
information it turns out because these
are frigging spy and you said but
doesn't that make Obama look bad that's
right so before the show I was saying
well then how did they let Obama keep
going out there and keep saying he's a
low-level because that's what they do
they discredit so whoever is blows gives
out information that they don't want to
give out they discredit him just like
they did with Valerie Plame and her
husband when he discredited them so it's
just they the conspiracies happen right
out in the open and when someone says
hey this is a good thing that's
happening they just discredit him and
that's exactly what he's saying this
they've been doing so do you think Obama
knew and then yes you think someone else
here maybe wait until we get some look
there's gonna the the governess the
United States gonna say something
different about what his level of spying
was right my hunch is that there is
probably a way that you can have his if
if you're to believe is a low level
position you actually described look
he's a low level position who if it is a
low level position who installed systems
for the National Security Administration
to keep our secrets safe like it's not
like a low-level employee at the Young
Turks I mean fact like it so a janitor
this way level stuff was still pretty
right so even like my there may not even
be a difference in analogy what he did
it's just characterizing it like the NSA
might say listen they were is 37 people
to report to before he got to the NSA
and he'd go I was essentially spy that's
why like III already see a conversation
devolving nationally about this that
then I wouldn't be that interested in
like I'm interested in his politics and
what motivated him and is he gonna get
prosecuted like that stuff interest me
again none of it is as important as that
what he released and how we react to
that as a country right so as you're
both saying of course the government is
going to look to
discredit him and he addressed that now
the government might deny these things
they might frame it in certain ways and
say oh well you know he's a low-level
analyst but what they're trying to do is
they're trying to use one position that
I've had in a career here or there to
distract from the totality of my
experience which is that I've worked for
the Central Intelligence Agency
undercover overseas I've worked for the
National Security Agency undercover
overseas and I've worked for the Defense
Intelligence Agency as a lecturer at the
joint counterintelligence training
academy where I developed sources and
methods for keeping our information and
people secure in the most hostile and
dangerous environments around the world
so when they say I'm a little level
Systems Administrator that I don't know
what I'm talking about
I'd say it's somewhat misleading I'm
obviously very Pro Snowden I'm Pro the
release of all these actions there is
something a slightly cryptic about him
right and maybe that just comes with the
job you know I was watching the sea we
watched it together CNN's take on that
they ran that clip in the CNN anchor I
can't identify but he could play an
anchorman on virtually any television
show very professional very professional
afterwards he said quote a lot of energy
he's putting into giving a sense of
importance to his position
CNN won't take a stand on climate change
right right I mean they could literally
bring someone on the network who'll deny
that evolution exists but they'll take a
shot at Snowden at the first opportunity
uh so I think you will see a lot of that
that said he was really into giving
himself a sense of importance that but
if you were being minimized by other
people you're natural any person's
natural response would be to say no no
you're wrong you're right we can't get
too caught up in the nuance of every
little thing he says and how he says it
because that's not what this is really
about yeah
so I think that if you're a CNN going
back to your point if you're gonna try
and discredit Edward Snowden you have to
do it with facts like oh yeah he said he
was a spy turns out he wasn't
turns out he said he said he worked
overseas doing this he did it you can't
just go wow he's putting a lot of the
trying and look like he's important well
then he said what he said was this ball
well
it was true everything he said he was
but that's what's [ __ ] about that's
the anything was total [ __ ] was a
weird bit of editorializing and there's
only one response to this is you call
the DIA and the CIA and the NSA and you
say what was his job and they go we're
not telling you and then you say by the
way we call these people to see their as
Don was telling the truth and they
wouldn't comment right so I'm moving the
next [ __ ] story I'm gonna guess CNN
will do that but somebody might do that
so my final thought is you think this
guy's ever stepping foot in the US again
no is there any chance definitely not
maybe if Jimmy Carter's president again
step foot me you I look I'm gonna just -
I there's a scenario where he sets foot
in the US and he spends a little bit of
time in jail that worked out and that's
what I do that's how I handle I put him
in jail I've never been consistent on
that I wouldn't put in that would throw
them away oh he's not he not a traitor
right uh but you know some of the things
he gave up were things that he should be
given up because he gave up so much
stuff it turned out there was some stuff
in there probably should have gone the
NSA stuff is incredibly important that
we all know like it put the guy in jail
for three years we could write gonna be
a federal he'd be fine he'd write a book
you get gazillionaire after right
everybody wins sometimes we just do this
ourselves you know Obama went to
Afghanistan the other day and we
accidentally outed one of our own spies
by putting them on a list of people that
run show up at Obama's event so we do it
whether Snowden's doing this or not Karl
Rove by the way goes on Fox News in
comparison to Valerie Plame's is worse
the value plane he did intentionally and
then lies about it on a regular base
that's a whole other story all right